Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 没有多余的
Shure: There's no extra ones.
Lucia: 可以了
Lucia: It's okay.
Shure: 皮套之类的东西吗
Shure: Things like hair ties?
Lucia: 多余的什么
Lucia: Extra what?
Shure: 皮套之类的
Shure: Like hair ties.
Lucia: 什么叫皮套
Lucia: What's a hair tie?
Shure: 就是扎头发那种
Shure: It's like a rubber band for hair.
Lucia: 啊皮筋啊
Lucia: Ah, a rubber band.
Shure: 对皮筋
Shure: Yes, a rubber band.
Lucia: 好什么皮套叫皮筋啊
Lucia: Why are you calling a rubber band a hair tie?
Jake:呀你这鞋还是同款的呀
Jake: Hey, your shoes are the same model!
Jake:怎么做到的
Jake: How did you manage that?
Shure: 呃也不是
Shure: Uh, not really.
Shure: 就是买了点彩虹元素
Shure: I just bought some with rainbow elements.
Shure: 但是本人并不是的
Shure: But I'm not actually into that.
Jake:oh
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 我要把头发扎起来太长了
Shure: I need to tie my hair up, it's too long.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Mhm.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Choiszt: 现在能够
Choiszt: Can you now?
Tasha: 不会谢掉吧
Tasha: It won't fall off, right?
Alice: 永不凋谢的花
Alice: A flower that never withers.
Jake:嚯这糖怎么办
Jake: What should we do with this candy?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jake:给它融了倒掉是吧
Jake: Just melt it and pour it out, right?
Lucia: 倒了
Lucia: Poured it out.
Shure: 哦这还有两个真好
Shure: Oh, there are two more here, great.
Jake:呃我看一下
Jake: Uh, let me see.
Jake:问一下
Jake: Let me ask.
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello?
Jake:Rainbow人吗
Jake: Is Rainbow there?
Alice: 扔吗
Alice: Throw it away?
Lucia: 嗯扔什么
Lucia: Hmm, throw what away?
Lucia: 嗷
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:这小包要不要一个
Jake: Do you want one of these small packs?
Jake:收拾好了
Jake: All cleaned up.
Katrina: 走不走看狗去
Katrina: Shall we go see the dog?
Katrina: 然后要回来搞搞饭了
Katrina: Then we need to come back and make dinner.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:对去看狗吧
Jake: Yeah, let's go see the dog.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 他还在吗
Katrina: Is he still there?
Katrina: 他俩去吗
Katrina: Are they going?
Choiszt: 应该在你们俩去看
Choiszt: They should be there. You two go check.
Katrina: 你们俩去吗
Katrina: Are you two going?
Katrina: 你俩去吗
Jake:你俩开导了吗
Jake: Have you two talked them into it?
Alice:卫生间收了吗
Alice: Has the bathroom been cleaned?
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 楼上那个洗手间也换一下可以吗
Lucia: Can you also change the trash bag in the upstairs bathroom?
Lucia: 就是垃圾袋
Lucia: Just the trash bag.
Lucia: 哦好谢谢啊
Lucia: Oh, thanks a lot.
Lucia: 哦也行
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
Shure: 这箱子我们留着还有点用
Shure: Let's keep this box, it might still be useful.
Lucia: 昂
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 啊可以的
Lucia: Ah, it's fine.
Lucia: 只要就是主要就是那个垃圾桶
Lucia: The main thing is just the trash can.
Lucia: 收拾一下就行了
Lucia: Just clean it up a bit.
Choiszt: 我把其他插进去
Choiszt: I'll plug in the other stuff.
Lucia: 呃这边的这些箱纸箱吗
Lucia: Uh, these cardboard boxes here?
Lucia: 这这这这个都可以不要了然后
Lucia: These, these, these, we don't need them anymore and...
Lucia: 呃这个这个也不要了
Lucia: Uh, we don't need this one either.
Lucia: 这里面这些我看一眼啊应该
Lucia: Let me take a quick look at these, should be fine.
Lucia: 对这都是不用了
Lucia: Yeah, we don't need these.
Lucia: 对对然后这也是
Lucia: Yeah, and this one too.
Lucia: 嗯对那个应该是外卖垃圾
Lucia: Hmm, yeah, that's probably trash from the delivery.
Lucia: 对对对然后这个这个箱子也不要了
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, and we don't need this box either.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 其他有几个我们好像还没
Lucia: There are a few other things we haven't...
Lucia: 没看这京东快递
Lucia: Haven't checked this JD delivery yet.
Lucia: 这刚拿回来的吗
Lucia: Did we just get this?
Lucia: 先放这吧
Lucia: Let's just leave it here for now.
Lucia: 呃这个别的这个好像还没拆
Lucia: Uh, and this one, we haven't opened it yet.
Lucia: 这边这些是要用的
Lucia: These over here, we need to use.
Lucia: 呃对这这是要用啊
Lucia: Uh, yeah, we need to use this one.
Lucia: 对这些不要了
Lucia: Yeah, we don't need these.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 呃对这些先别动吧这些我不确定
Lucia: Uh, yeah, let's not touch these yet. I'm not sure.
Lucia: 我同学他们收拾了没
Lucia: Not sure if my classmates have sorted them.
Lucia: 呃这个可以不要了
Lucia: Uh, we can throw this away.
Lucia: 这个是那个外卖的盒
Lucia: This is the delivery box.
Lucia: 对然后其他这些我们再给他看一下
Lucia: Yeah, and let's check these other things again.
Lucia: 啊这个这个扔了吧
Lucia: Ah, just throw this away.
Katrina: 哈哈够了真的是
Katrina: Haha, that's enough, seriously.
Katrina: 走吧你们去不去
Katrina: Let's go, are you coming?
Jake:来对齐对齐
Jake: Come on, align it, align it.
Lucia: 哎咱门口就是
Lucia: Hey, it's right by our door.
Lucia: 那那些箱子是已经收拾过的吗
Lucia: Are those boxes already packed?
Lucia: 就门口最最最最头这些这些我不太确定
Lucia: I'm not too sure about the ones right at the front.
Jake:这些其实都不用都不用
Jake: These actually aren't needed, not needed.
Lucia: 就这些都不用那有的
Lucia: So these aren't needed, but some are.
Lucia: 啊那也行
Lucia: Ah, that's fine too.
Lucia: 这个这个也是个外卖袋子是吗
Lucia: Is this also a takeout bag?
Lucia: 外卖袋子就扔了吧对这个
Lucia: Just throw away the takeout bags, yeah, this one.
Jake:外卖可以
Jake: Takeout is fine.
Lucia: 哎行行谢谢
Lucia: Alright, alright, thanks.
Lucia: 这些盒
Lucia: These boxes...
Lucia: 这些盒好像都还挺结实可以放一下
Lucia: These boxes seem pretty sturdy, we can keep them.
Lucia: 啊谢谢您啊
Lucia: Ah, thank you.
Jake:亮灯了哎
Jake: The light's on, hey.
Jake:亮了亮了
Jake: It's on, it's on.
Lucia: 晾了吧好的
Lucia: Let it dry, okay.
Katrina: go go
Katrina: Go go
Jake:暗中
Jake: In secret
Lucia: 哎又校准一次
Lucia: Ah, calibrate it again
Katrina:  你们对一下表
Katrina: You guys synchronize your watches
Shure: 你要你要
Shure: You need to, you need to
Shure: 你要在我这里面开
Shure: You need to start it here with me
Jake:你没电了
Jake: You're out of battery
Jake:不亮了
Jake: It's not lighting up
Jake:那是怎么回事
Jake: What's going on
Katrina: 走不走走不走
Katrina: Are we going or not
Jake:看看你的电
Jake: Check your battery
Katrina: 要走赶紧走
Katrina: If we're going, let's go now
Jake:还是他会这有电
Jake: Or it's him, he has power
Jake:插上的
Jake: It's plugged in
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay
Katrina: 很艺术你看那画家的感觉走不走
Katrina: It's very artistic, look at that painter's feeling, are we going or not
Shure: 谢
Shure: Thanks
Shure: 校准一下
Shure: Calibrate it
Nicous: 哎你这个头发很很日式
Nicous: Hey, your hair looks very Japanese
Shure: 霓虹几乌鸡豆
Shure: Neon chicken udon
Choiszt: 上个厕所
Choiszt: Going to the restroom
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go
Jake:所以
Jake: So
Katrina: 溜一圈回来
Katrina: Go for a round and come back
Katrina: 今天还没出去透气
Katrina: Haven't gone out for fresh air today
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go
Jake:所以你要开一下
Jake: So you need to start it
Shure: 咱去走
Shure: Let's go
Katrina: 他俩上厕所要等他俩吗
Katrina: They are going to the restroom, should we wait for them?
Jake:还得再浇水
Jake: Need to water again
Shure: 哪有人上厕所
Shure: Who's going to the restroom
Choiszt: 啊这儿没有厕所
Choiszt: Ah, there's no restroom here
Nicous: 厕所在这儿
Nicous: The restroom is here
Choiszt: 你帮我看着点
Choiszt: Keep an eye for me
Katrina: 两小时衣服就干了
Katrina: The clothes will be dry in two hours
Lucia: 虽然很难想
Lucia: Though it's hard to imagine
Lucia: 不过我觉得我有一个大概的计划了
Lucia: But I think I have a rough plan
Alice:你选了几呀
Alice: Which ones did you choose
Lucia: 我就是我计划里的
Lucia: It's just part of my plan
Lucia: 现在有一二三四五个
Lucia: Now there are one, two, three, four, five of them
Jake:你要等一
Jake: You need to wait a
Jake:会
Jake: bit
Lucia: 五个东西就是可以用来装饰一下的
Lucia: These five items can be used for decoration
Lucia: 不过还没下单
Lucia: But I haven't placed the order yet
Alice:有点少
Alice: That's a bit few
Lucia: 因为我还没想好然后可能
Lucia: Because I haven't decided yet, and maybe
Lucia: 可能再加一点贴纸或者之类的东西
Lucia: Maybe I'll add some stickers or something
Alice:我
Alice: I
Tasha:不可能就四五四五啊我也差不多吧
Tasha: It can't be just four or five, I guess I have about the same
Jake:没关系你一会再拍吧
Jake: It's okay, you can take the photo later
Tasha:啊3445个差不多
Tasha: Uh, around 34 or 45 is about right
Lucia: 如果我们有预算
Lucia: If we have the budget
Lucia: 我是不是可以买个娃娃
Lucia: Can I buy a doll
Lucia: 把它当成装饰
Lucia: And use it as a decoration
Lucia: 最后再带回去
Lucia: Then take it back home later
Lucia: 就是符合我的那个风格的
Lucia: It matches my style
Alice:设计怎么样了
Alice: How's the design going?
Tasha:嗯满多的日对蛮多的
Tasha: Uh, there are quite a lot, yeah quite a lot
Lucia: 抄作业哈哈哈
Lucia: Copying homework, haha
Alice: 没有没有
Alice: No, no
Tasha:有一些内种
Tasha: There are some of that kind
Tasha:画装饰画
Tasha: Painting decorative paintings
Tasha:地毯
Tasha: Carpets
Alice:啊我也喜欢地毯
Alice: Ah, I also like carpets
Lucia: 啊哎
Lucia: Ah, hey
Lucia: 我没有放地毯
Lucia: I didn't put a carpet
Lucia: 不过我因为我那个房间进去那个空间
Lucia: But because in my room, when you enter that space
Lucia: 它是有一个那
Lucia: There's a
Lucia: 样的然后再进去我觉得不是很好选
Lucia: thing, then when you go in, I think it's not easy to choose
Alice:的嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right
Lucia: 地毯我就没选
Lucia: So I didn't choose a carpet
Lucia: 哦不过咱俩户型是一样的应该
Lucia: But our layouts are the same, I think
Lucia: 我想搞一个
Lucia: I want to get one
Alice:那我们现在正在录的话
Alice: If we're recording now
Alice:应该可以说了吧
Alice: We should be able to talk about it
Lucia: 对可以说了吧
Lucia: Yeah, we can talk about it
Lucia: 咱不是专门把这个留着
Lucia: We're not specifically saving this for later
Alice:因为
Alice: Because
Lucia: 但是微微的还没打开
Lucia: But Tasha hasn't opened it yet
Lucia: 应该没关系
Lucia: It should be okay
Lucia: 我想弄一个
Lucia: I want to make one.
Lucia: 就是那种毛毡照片墙
Lucia: Like a felt photo wall.
Lucia: 就可以拿土丁往上戳照片的那个
Lucia: You know, the kind you can pin photos onto.
Lucia: 然后我看他好像买那个照片墙
Lucia: And I saw that when you buy the photo wall,
Lucia: 就会送美文纸
Lucia: they give you some nice paper.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 我就可以直接贴在墙上
Lucia: So I can just stick it directly on the wall.
Lucia: 对那你想做什么风格
Lucia: Yeah, what style do you want to go for?
Alice:那你想做什么风格呢
Alice: Yeah, what style do you want to go for?
Lucia: 其实我想做蓝色系
Lucia: Actually, I'm thinking of a blue theme.
Alice:我昨天想过
Alice: I thought about it yesterday.
Alice:但是
Alice: But
Lucia: 你现在
Lucia: Right now,
Alice:我就是没有找到我喜欢的那个蓝色
Alice: I just couldn't find the blue I liked.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:然后我就换了换成
Alice: So I switched to
Alice:森林的那种感觉
Alice: a forest kind of feeling.
Lucia: 啊我现在
Lucia: Ah, right now,
Alice:嗯绿色的其实我不是很喜欢绿色
Alice: Hmm, green, but I'm not really into green.
Lucia: 我现在
Lucia: Right now,
Lucia: 我现在想法可能是做一点偏地中海
Lucia: I'm thinking maybe something Mediterranean.
Alice:海洋
Alice: Ocean
Lucia: 对对对对那种风格
Lucia: Yes, yes, that kind of style.
Lucia: 所以我想再买一个
Lucia: So I want to buy another one.
Lucia: 再买一张渔网
Lucia: And then buy a fishing net.
Lucia: 然后咱们把它挂一下
Lucia: And hang it up.
Lucia: 我刚就是在想怎样挂会比较好看
Lucia: I was just thinking about how to hang it to look nice.
Alice:那个渔网
Alice: That fishing net
Alice:挂的话你是不是可以买点什么水母啊
Alice: If you hang it, maybe you could add some jellyfish,
Alice:或者贝壳那种元素在上面
Alice: or shells as elements.
Lucia: 对我也是在想这个
Lucia: Yeah, I was thinking about that too.
Lucia: 就把它点缀一下
Lucia: Just to decorate it a bit.
Lucia: 但我还在想怎么挂
Lucia: But I'm still figuring out how to hang it.
Lucia: 就要不然把它直接挂在照片墙上
Lucia: Maybe just hang it on the photo wall.
Lucia: 然后再然后再在那个渔网上面戳照片
Lucia: And then pin photos onto the fishing net.
Alice:我昨天瘦了一圈
Alice: I lost some weight yesterday.
Lucia: 但我好像没
Lucia: But I don't think
Lucia: 我觉得现在好像不太来得及打印照片
Lucia: I don't think I'll have time to print photos now.
Lucia: 我要不要买几张图算了
Lucia: Maybe I should just buy some pictures.
Lucia: 可能也很便宜买几张明信片
Lucia: Maybe we can buy some postcards cheaply too.
Alice:昨天想了很多的
Alice: I thought a lot about it yesterday.
Alice:呃星星就水星海母贝壳用海洋元素
Alice: Uh, stars, Mercury, seashells, using ocean elements.
Alice:然后发现就没有喜欢的那种蓝色
Alice: And then I realized there wasn't the kind of blue I liked.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:我就我就换了
Alice: So I changed it.
Alice:你看这个是我自己的那个小海星
Alice: Look, this is my own little starfish.
Alice:我就真的很喜欢海洋
Alice: I just really love the ocean.
Lucia: 好好看哇好好看
Lucia: It's so pretty, really pretty.
Lucia: 这是你自己自己设计的吗
Lucia: Did you design this yourself?
Lucia: 自己做的啊
Lucia: Made it yourself?
Lucia: 好看耶
Lucia: Looks great!
Lucia: 我想想我们学校之前有一个课
Lucia: I remember we had a class at school once.
Lucia: 就他有点像电工实习
Lucia: It was kind of like an electrical internship.
Lucia: 但不完全一样
Lucia: But not exactly.
Lucia: 就是也会自己做节制
Lucia: We also made things ourselves.
Lucia: 对然后我当时做的也是一个星星
Lucia: Yeah, and I made a star too.
Lucia: 不过不是
Lucia: But it wasn't
Jake:卢亚来帮帮个忙帮个忙
Jake: Lucia, can you help me out?
Lucia: 海星啊怎么了
Lucia: A starfish? What's up?
Jake:那个有有点离谱
Jake: It's kind of ridiculous.
Lucia: what's wrong
Lucia: What's wrong?
Jake:我一不小心按到了这个电源键
Jake: I accidentally pressed the power button.
Jake:我要松的话我就凉了
Jake: If I let go, we're doomed.
Lucia: 哈哈哈所以
Lucia: Hahaha, so...
Jake:所以
Jake: So...
Jake:所以你要帮我把所有硬盘都退出去
Jake: So you need to help me eject all the hard drives.
Lucia: 怎么退
Lucia: How do I eject them?
Jake:就是就是那个退出退出
Jake: Just, just eject them.
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a sec.
Lucia: 天呐不是您真的情绪好稳定
Lucia: Wow, you're really calm under pressure.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:好稳哈哈哈
Jake: So steady, hahaha.
Jake:就是地雷知道吧
Jake: It's like a landmine, you know?
Lucia: 我我我怎样怎样
Lucia: What do I do, what do I do?
Jake:哎右下角有一个这个USB看到对
Jake: Hey, there's a USB icon in the bottom right corner, see it?
Lucia: 右下角嗯嗯OK
Lucia: Bottom right, mm-hmm, okay.
Jake:然后退出退出
Jake: Then eject, eject.
Lucia: 你这里有一个输入法
Lucia: There's an input method here.
Lucia: 我帮你挪一下可以吗
Lucia: Can I move it for you?
Jake:啊不用不用
Jake: Ah, no need, no need.
Jake:你就直接点左边的这个
Jake: Just click on the one on the left.
Tasha: 天哪
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia: 最下下面的这个就是退出号
Lucia: The one at the very bottom is the logout button.
Jake:最下面最下面这个对对对
Jake: The very bottom one, yes, that one.
Lucia: 他得退一会吗不
Lucia: Does he need to log out for a while?
Jake:啊你摁一下
Jake: Ah, just press it.
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What's up?
Tasha: 我说重新拿一瓶吧能能
Tasha: I'm thinking of getting a new bottle, can we?
Jake:嗯使劲摁
Jake: Yeah, press hard.
Jake:或者你摁
Jake: Or you press it.
Jake:哎对
Jake: Yeah, that's it.
Alice:桌上只有两瓶
Alice: There's only two bottles on the table.
Alice:应该就是我放的那一瓶
Alice: It should be the one I put there.
Lucia: 弹出失败
Lucia: Ejection failed.
Jake:哦呃呃
Jake: Oh, uh...
Lucia: 那就取消一下再试一次
Lucia: Then cancel it and try again.
Lucia: 你看哪个电脑比较方便
Lucia: 我先操作那个电脑
Lucia: 然后接下来的我就可以照本宣科了
Jake:好你看我
Jake:还是没看哎这样子
Jake: Still not looking, huh, like this.
Jake:啊就是就是这个
Jake: Ah, it's just this.
Lucia: 啊原来不是统一的嗯
Lucia: Oh, so it's not standardized, huh.
Jake:哎有的其实就是
Jake: Yeah, some of it is, actually.
Jake:嘿嘿哎搞笑嗯
Jake: Haha, it's funny, huh.
Lucia: 一会等他们回来
Lucia: We'll wait for them to come back.
Lucia: 我要我要给他们讲这个故事
Lucia: I want to tell them this story.
Jake:这个故事确实挺好讲
Jake: This story is definitely worth telling.
Lucia: 不行您真的情绪太稳定了
Lucia: No way, you're way too calm.
Jake:能补救还没死
Jake: There's still a chance, it's not over yet.
Alice:但是你这个就是一只
Alice: But yours is just one.
Alice:上面就好几个头
Alice: And there's several heads on top.
Alice:就这种高度
Alice: At this height.
Alice:这个高度是没办法变的
Alice: This height can't be changed.
Jake:拔出
Jake: Pull it out.
Lucia: 对吧他好像有点不是很灵光的样子
Lucia: Right? It seems like it's not working properly.
Lucia: 你你在这里操作一下呢看
Lucia: Can you try operating it here?
Lucia: 对他刚才就会提示这个
Lucia: Yeah, it just showed this prompt.
Alice:外边纸箱吗
Alice: The cardboard box outside?
Lucia: 弹出失败什么什么的
Lucia: Something about a pop-up failure
Alice:要不先留一下
Alice: Maybe we should save it first
Jake:可以有
Jake: Sure, we can do that
Alice:哦谢谢阿姨
Alice: Oh, thanks, Auntie
Jake:有弹出嘛
Jake: Is there a pop-up?
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh
Lucia: 我感觉好像没有
Lucia: I don't think there is
Jake:可能要到这点
Jake: Maybe it will show up later
Lucia: 啊你这个还在备份
Lucia: Ah, you're still backing up
Jake:到实践了
Jake: It's time to practice
Lucia: 此电脑
Lucia: This computer
Jake:哎呦我去实践了啊
Jake: Oh, I'm going to practice now
Jake:到这个右键
Jake: Right-click here
Jake:这也没有
Jake: There's nothing here either
Lucia: 好像没有属性底下就没别的了吧
Lucia: Seems like there's nothing under properties
Lucia: 呃确实属性下就没别了
Lucia: Uh, there's really nothing under properties
Jake:我靠这沙雕360
Jake: Damn this stupid 360
Jake:我先把360关了
Jake: I'll turn off 360 first
Lucia: 那用他自带的那个优盘弹出试试看
Lucia: How about trying to eject it with the built-in tool
Jake:对就是他
Jake: Yes, that's it
Tasha: 今天也不去拿快递是吗
Tasha: Not picking up the package today either?
Jake:什么快递
Jake: What package?
Tasha: 啊嗯没有人拿要不下次再拿吧
Tasha: Uh, no one's picking it up, maybe we'll get it next time
Jake:你要去拿快递吗
Jake: Are you going to pick up the package?
Jake:呃你说今天有些快递到了
Jake: Uh, you said some packages arrived today
Tasha: 我上午的时候好像就说有
Tasha: I think I mentioned it this morning
Jake:哦会有然后你手机他怎么跟你讲
Jake: Oh, so there are. What did your phone say?
Tasha: 他跟我说他在
Tasha: It said it's here
Lucia: 要不然试试这个
Lucia: How about trying this
Jake:他他说哎
Jake: It said, hey
Jake:现在可以360
Jake: Now you can use 360
Lucia: 那要不把把那个
Lucia: How about we use that
Jake:口琴对就行了
Jake: Harmonica, that works
Lucia: 就是啊这样就弹出来那个
Lucia: Yeah, like this, it will eject
Jake:你继续说
Jake: Keep talking
Jake:我没再再再讲一下
Jake: I'll explain again
Tasha: 他说他今天现在在
Tasha: He said he's here now
Jake:现在在好
Jake: He's here now, okay
Tasha: 嗯但其实不是很重要的快递
Tasha: Uh-huh, but it's not an important package
Lucia: 另
Lucia: Also...
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:你你你跟房东讲你他让你怎么取啊
Jake: You, you, you tell the landlord, how did he tell you to pick it up?
Jake:你报手机尾号是吧
Jake: You need to report the last four digits of your phone number, right?
Jake:应该是吧
Jake: It should be, right?
Tasha: 应该吧我不知道9707
Tasha: I guess, I don't know, 9707.
Jake:你手机尾号是什么
Jake: What's the last four digits of your phone number?
Jake:京东
Jake: JD.com
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:京东
Jake: JD.com
Tasha: 那他是房东拿来送来了吗
Tasha: Did the landlord bring it over?
Jake:还好有两只手
Jake: Good thing I have two hands.
Lucia: 哈哈哈您怎么情绪这么稳定
Lucia: Hahaha, how are you so calm?
Jake:对京京东
Jake: Yes, JD.com
Jake:呃是的是的
Jake: Uh, yes, yes.
Jake:111707
Jake: 111707
Tasha: 9707
Jake:9707
Jake: 9707
Jake:好的哎呦
Jake: Okay, got it.
Lucia: 是不是也可以让他拿了快递
Lucia: Can he also pick up the package and bring it over?
Lucia: 然后送过来
Lucia: And then deliver it?
Jake:我去是是的是的
Jake: Oh, yes, yes.
Lucia: 就是这个民宿管家啊太好了
Lucia: This homestay manager is amazing.
Jake:就是可以不兜
Jake: You can avoid it.
Jake:风他们其实不想让我们兜风
Jake: They actually don't want us to go out.
Lucia:  这个没有360就直接弹出呗
Lucia: This one pops up without 360 degrees.
Jake:对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:这个就好
Jake: This one is good.
Jake:这就好点了
Jake: This is better.
Jake:早上的那个毫米波也是因为360转了
Jake: The millimeter wave this morning was also because of the 360-degree turn.
Jake:很多马
Jake: So many horses.
Lucia: 我点完之后哎
Lucia: After I clicked it...
Lucia: 这是安全弹出的意思
Lucia: Does this mean it's safely popped up?
Lucia: 他这个小弹的是吧
Lucia: This small pop-up, right?
Jake:这边没有哎
Jake: There's nothing here.
Lucia: 对没有了
Lucia: Yeah, it's gone.
Jake:这边没有
Jake: There's nothing here.
Lucia: 应该没有
Lucia: There shouldn't be anything.
Jake:那就行这个是修硕的
Jake: That's fine, this one is Shure's.
Jake:修硕也把它给关掉
Jake: Shure also turned it off.
Jake:然后这个是
Jake: And this is
Lucia: 这SELYX雨轩的吧
Lucia: This is SELYX Yuxuan's, right?
Jake:这是对宇轩的
Jake: This is for Yuxuan
Lucia: 可能是好
Lucia: Maybe it's good
Jake:好弹出来了给他关掉
Jake: Okay, it popped up, let's close it
Jake:对然后这是Lucia的
Jake: Yeah and this is for Lucia
Lucia: 然后这个
Lucia: And this one
Jake:坐坐
Jake: Have a seat
Jake:你不用像我这么慌
Jake: No need to be as anxious as me
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈我觉得我比你要慌一些
Lucia: Hahaha I think I'm more anxious than you
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 您怎么情绪这么稳定
Lucia: How come you're so calm?
Lucia: 这个好像也没有360
Lucia: This doesn't seem like 360
Lucia: 也是直接点这个呗
Lucia: Just click this, right?
Lucia: 现在
Lucia: Now
Lucia: AI是不是收集到了一些很神奇的数据
Lucia: Has the AI collected some amazing data?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake:现在知道怎么让人不关机
Jake: Now we know how to prevent shutdowns
Jake:怎么让自己不关机
Jake: How to prevent ourselves from shutting down
Lucia: 他现在他提示这个安全移除
Lucia: Now it's prompting for safe removal
Lucia: 就是代表OK了OK
Lucia: That means it's OK, OK
Jake:这就OK了
Jake: It's OK now
Jake:OK了
Jake: OK
Jake:然后这个就是卢西亚的我就关掉了
Jake: And this one is for Lucia, I'll turn it off
Lucia: ok
Lucia: Ok
Jake:好
Jake: Alright
Jake:帮我操作了一番
Jake: You helped me operate it
Jake:体验体验卡体验卡
Jake: Experience card, experience card
Lucia: 哈这是多少
Lucia: Ha, how much is this?
Lucia: 六六 7个屏幕体验卡
Lucia: Six, six, 7-screen experience card
Lucia: 这好像也没有360
Lucia: This doesn't seem like 360
Jake:对对挺好
Jake: Yeah, yeah, pretty good
Jake:对就这上面呢有个360
Jake: Yes, there is a 360 on it
Lucia: 那就直接直接弹出就行
Lucia: Then just pop it out directly
Lucia: 这个这个窗口要关吗
Lucia: Should I close this window?
Jake:不用管不用管
Jake: Ignore it, ignore it
Lucia: 不用管它
Lucia: Ignore it
Lucia: 我觉得电脑是一个
Lucia: I think the computer is a
Lucia: 经常莫名其妙就自己抽分的玩意
Lucia: It often just acts up on its own for no reason.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 就是也可能因为我不是学这个的啊
Lucia: Maybe it's because I didn't study this field.
Jake:哈是他确实确实会丑确实会丑
Jake: Haha, yes, it indeed can be quite annoying.
Lucia: 但总之我经常这么觉得
Lucia: But anyway, I often feel this way.
Lucia: 这应该应该也好了
Lucia: This should be fixed now.
Jake:嗯好好没问题
Jake: Hmm, okay, no problem.
Lucia: 这个我看不到那个那个啥了
Lucia: I can't see that thing anymore.
Lucia: 他应该已经弹出
Lucia: It should have popped out already.
Lucia: 对这个是z z z x是水L3 这是
Lucia: Yeah, this is z z z x is water L3, this is...
Jake:呃张夏是微微微
Jake: Uh, Zhang Xia is slightly, slightly, slightly...
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Jake:要不给我拍个照吧
Jake: How about you take a picture for me?
Lucia: 这个这个好像就有
Lucia: This, this seems to have...
Lucia: 就有360啊
Lucia: It has 360, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 这你看不到是吗
Lucia: You can't see it, can you?
Jake:不是给我拍个照
Jake: No, just take a picture for me.
Lucia: 啊你你现在啊
Lucia: Ah, you mean now?
Jake:哈哈哈对好行
Jake: Haha, yes, right now.
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then.
Lucia: 我拿你手机拍也行
Lucia: I can use your phone to take it.
Jake:哎对都都行都行
Jake: Yeah, sure, that works.
Lucia: 啊那行有什么想要的角度吗
Lucia: Ah, okay. Any specific angle you want?
Jake:没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Lucia: 你哪个角度比较比较觉
Lucia: Which angle do you think looks best?
Lucia: 自己觉得比较好看的可以
Lucia: The one you think looks the best is fine.
Jake:哈哈没有没有
Jake: Haha, no, no.
Lucia: 那要不看镜头
Lucia: How about you look at the camera?
Lucia: 1二三OK
Lucia: 1, 2, 3, okay.
Lucia: 一会发您
Lucia: I'll send it to you later.
Jake:your time都可以啊
Jake: Anytime, that's fine.
Lucia: 还是发群里
Lucia: Or send it to the group.
Jake:群里可以
Jake: Group is fine.
Lucia: 刚到哪了
Lucia: Where were we?
Lucia: 这个这个是有360的
Lucia: This, this one has 360.
Jake:那就关掉360
Jake: Then just turn off 360.
Lucia: 咋咋关
Lucia: How, how do you turn it off?
Jake:对右下角有一个这个
Jake: There's one in the bottom right corner.
Lucia: 三角那个吗这个
Lucia: The triangle one?
Jake:对然后右键关掉它
Jake: Yes, then right-click to close it.
Lucia: 退出
Lucia: Exit.
Jake:还好屋里有人
Jake: Good thing there's someone in the room.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:要不然我就在这盯着盯到各位回家
Jake: Otherwise, I'd be here watching until everyone goes home.
Lucia: 等到大家回来
Lucia: Until everyone comes back.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 然后再再那个用Windows自带的那个
Lucia: Then use the built-in Windows one.
Lucia: 弹出
Lucia: Eject.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 应该没有了
Lucia: There shouldn't be anything left.
Lucia: 他那个窗口就消失了看一眼
Lucia: The window disappeared, take a look.
Lucia: OK这个是s
Lucia: Okay, this is "s".
Lucia: s k x
Lucia: "s", "k", "x".
Jake:对对是了
Jake: Yes, yes, that's it.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: ok
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 上来这个我们已经退过了吗
Lucia: Did we exit this one already?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Lucia: 哦还没有哦
Lucia: Oh, not yet.
Jake:刚好是310
Jake: It's exactly 310.
Jake:没有成功把他盘他
Jake: Didn't manage to eject it successfully.
Lucia: okok
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 这外面是直升机吗
Lucia: Is that a helicopter outside?
Lucia: 这个声音
Lucia: That sound.
Lucia: 哦哦sorry
Lucia: Oh, oh, sorry.
Jake:我我我不知道
Jake: I, I, I don't know.
Jake:有可能是直升机
Jake: It could be a helicopter.
Lucia: 听着真的很像直升机
Lucia: It really sounds like a helicopter.
Lucia: 但这个地方有什么必要
Lucia: But is there a need for one here?
Jake:或者是飞机
Jake: Or maybe a plane.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:盘旋
Jake: Hovering.
Jake:拖拉机
Jake: Tractor.
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 好了这是l e
Lucia: Alright, this is "l", "e".
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 这个东西不用管他吗
Lucia: Should we not bother with this?
Lucia: 就您这还有一个正在备份的
Lucia: You have another one that's backing up.
Jake:这个不用管我我已经火了
Jake: Don't worry about it, I'm already popular.
Lucia: 啊好
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 哈哈哈不用谢
Lucia: Hahaha, no need to thank me.
Jake:谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thanks, thanks, thanks, thanks.
Lucia: 我们中午吃饭
Lucia: We had lunch.
Lucia: 你还没上来的时候
Lucia: Before you came up.
Lucia: 大家其实在讨论你是不是一个AI
Lucia: Everyone was actually discussing if you are an AI.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈因为情绪过于稳定
Lucia: Hahaha, because your emotions are too stable.
Jake:不好是吧
Jake: Not good, right?
Jake:麻了
Jake: It's numbing.
Lucia: 不会吧真是个AI
Lucia: No way, are you really an AI?
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Lucia: 可以抄姐妹的作业吗
Lucia: Can I copy my sister's homework?
Alice: 可以
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 没有没有大家easy不会争吵看看有什么灵感
Lucia: No, no, everyone take it easy, no fighting, let's see if there's any inspiration.
Alice: 买个桌布
Alice: Buy a tablecloth.
Lucia: 哎这个桌布好看的
Lucia: Oh, this tablecloth is nice.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 我决定抄一下
Lucia: I decided to copy it.
Lucia: 不过改一个颜色
Lucia: But I'll change the color.
Lucia: 没有开玩笑开玩笑
Lucia: Just kidding, just kidding.
Alice:这个还行
Alice: This one's okay.
Alice:但不是我想要的那种颜色
Alice: But it's not the color I want.
Alice:但可以先加进去
Alice: But we can add it first.
Alice:然后慢慢删
Alice: Then slowly remove it.
Lucia: 我觉得我现在那几个装饰
Lucia: I think the decorations I have now.
Lucia: 都还是墙面的装饰
Lucia: They're all wall decorations.
Lucia: 没有什么桌子上的
Lucia: I don't have any for the table.
Lucia: 因为我那个房间里面没有
Lucia: Because in my room.
Lucia: 没有桌子
Lucia: There's no table.
Lucia: 他只有一个小架子
Lucia: There's only a small shelf.
Lucia: 你那里面有桌子吗
Lucia: Do you have a table in yours?
Alice:你可以去看
Alice: You can check.
Lucia: 呃可能会扫到
Lucia: Uh, it might get swept away.
Alice:无所谓我收拾过了哈哈哈
Alice: Doesn't matter, I cleaned up, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊那我看过了
Lucia: Ah, then I checked.
Lucia: 啊那我看一眼
Lucia: Ah, let me take a look.
Lucia: 会扫到
Lucia: It'll get scanned.
Alice:你看我我那有个桌子上上面有个灯
Alice: Look, I have a lamp on the table over there.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 哦哎
Lucia: Oh hey.
Lucia: 那你这个很好看
Lucia: That looks really nice.
Lucia: 我那里面只有一个架子
Lucia: I only have a shelf in mine.
Lucia: 就是像这种置物布局是一样的
Lucia: It's the same kind of storage layout.
Alice:今天不是一样的吗
Alice: Isn't it the same today?
Lucia: 但是就是它家具没有桌子
Lucia: But it doesn't have a table.
Lucia: 它只有一个置物架
Lucia: It only has a storage rack.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So,
Lucia: 我就想给那个置物架上再放一个
Lucia: I want to put another one on the storage rack.
Lucia: 那种小小的收纳
Lucia: A small storage box.
Lucia: 收纳箱那种
Lucia: A storage box.
Lucia: 让它整齐一些
Lucia: To make it tidier.
Lucia: 啊这个小灯挺好看的
Lucia: Ah, this small lamp is quite nice.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 我说那个小灯挺好看的
Lucia: I said the small lamp is quite nice.
Alice:你没有灯吗
Alice: Don't you have a lamp?
Lucia: 我没有
Lucia: I don't.
Alice:你只有上面的灯吗对
Alice: You only have the overhead light, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 是不是很amazing哈
Lucia: Isn't that amazing, huh?
Alice:我以为我们是等比例复制粘贴
Alice: I thought we were an exact copy and paste.
Lucia: 哈我们的房型是一样
Lucia: Ha, our room layout is the same,
Lucia: 但是里面的东西不太一样
Lucia: but the stuff inside is different.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 搞一个蓝色的什么布
Lucia: Get a blue cloth or something,
Lucia: 把床铺一铺好
Lucia: and make the bed nicely.
Tasha:没电了
Tasha: The power's out.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 复古流苏
Lucia: Vintage tassels.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Alice:什么材料包啊
Alice: What material pack is this?
Alice:材料包我得勾到什么时候去
Alice: How long do I have to crochet this material pack?
Lucia: 啊我知道了
Lucia: Ah, I got it.
Lucia: 我可以买一个宜家鲨鱼
Lucia: I can buy an IKEA shark.
Lucia: 因为我是地中海风
Lucia: Because I have a Mediterranean style.
Alice:是的
Alice: Right.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 为什么到这首歌声音突然变的这么小
Lucia: Why did the volume suddenly get so low for this song?
Lucia: 好像不可以
Lucia: It seems like it's not working.
Lucia: 因为这个电脑有锁啊
Lucia: Because this computer has a lock.
Lucia: 但我可以不同不打开他的锁
Lucia: But I can adjust the volume without unlocking it.
Lucia: 光调音量
Lucia: Just adjust the volume.
Alice:这个是算你的吗
Alice: Is this yours?
Alice:他是编织贝壳
Alice: It's made from woven shells.
Alice:有海滩的风格
Alice: It has a beach style.
Lucia: 哎哦这个好好看哎
Lucia: Oh, this looks so nice.
Alice:可以搜用贝壳什么的编织杯垫
Alice: You can search for shell-woven coasters.
Lucia: 这是杯垫是吗
Lucia: Is this a coaster?
Lucia: 我搜我搜搜看有没有类似的
Lucia: Let me search to see if there are similar ones.
Lucia: 虽然我可能
Lucia: Although I might...
Lucia: 我那个房间里面应该放不了
Lucia: I probably can't fit it in my room.
Lucia: 杯垫可以找找类似的其他的装饰
Lucia: Maybe I can find other similar decorations.
Shure: 怎么突然又多了几个碗啊
Shure: How come there are suddenly a few more bowls?
Lucia: 可能是桌上刚收过去的
Lucia: They might have just been cleared off the table.
Lucia: 这剩的这个
Lucia: This leftover...
Lucia: 反正碗都要洗了
Lucia: Anyway, the bowls need washing.
Lucia: 要不把它倒了吧
Lucia: How about we just dump it?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 早上是蘸白糖吃的吗
Shure: Was this eaten with sugar in the morning?
Lucia: 对哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Yeah, oh my!
Lucia: 这个充电线怎么又开了是的
Lucia: Why is this charging cable acting up again?
Shure: 好好好我来我来
Shure: Okay, okay, I'll do it.
Lucia: 我擦一下手
Lucia: I'll wipe my hands.
Lucia: 把这再带上
Lucia: And put this back on.
Choiszt: 这好像没加内个盐
Choiszt: It seems like there's no salt in this.
Shure: 加了点但加了不多
Shure: I added a bit, but not much.
Shure: 我不知道多少
Shure: I'm not sure how much.
Shure: 那些那些没有
Shure: Those, those don't have...
Shure: 腐乳什么的没有
Shure: No fermented tofu or anything.
Shure: 老北京二八酱是吧
Shure: Is this the old Beijing sauce?
Shure: 主要怕有人不吃什么的
Shure: Mainly worried some people might not eat it.
Shure: 美团现在送一点是来得及的
Shure: Meituan can deliver it quickly now.
Shure: 你美团点一下
Shure: Just order it on Meituan.
Shure: 要不
Shure: Otherwise...
Shure: 腐乳和韭菜花这俩
Shure: Fermented tofu and chive flower sauce.
Choiszt: 确实
Choiszt: Indeed.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Choiszt: 啊
Choiszt: Ah
Shure: 点吗
Shure: Are you ordering?
Choiszt: 我就问问齐康可以点
Choiszt: I’m just asking if Qikang can order.
Lucia: 斯啊
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 3525
Lucia: 25大概有这么宽
Lucia: 25 is about this wide.
Lucia: 好像也差不多了
Lucia: Seems about right.
Jake:不回来了吗
Jake: Not coming back?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:哈哈哈伤心哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, so sad, haha.
Shure: 人肤感就是
Shure: It feels like...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 人人机感和人肤感对
Shure: The feeling of human-machine interaction and human touch, right.
Jake:学到一些很难翻译的东西
Jake: Learning some hard-to-translate stuff.
Shure: 这怎么
Shure: How is this...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: host husband
Shure: Host husband.
Shure: style感feeling yeah
Shure: Style feeling, yeah.
Shure: feeling of host husband
Shure: Feeling of host husband.
Shure: 我去楼上吃饭一会
Shure: I’m going upstairs to eat for a bit.
Jake:对去布置布置
Shure: OK.
Shure: OK
Jake:我们拖桌子去吧
Jake: Let’s move the table.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Alice:为啥一看淘宝就困
Alice: Why do I get sleepy when I browse Taobao?
Lucia: 物业
Lucia: Property management.
Alice:是个重复性的工作
Alice: It’s repetitive work.
Alice:我一看我就犯困
Alice: As soon as I look at it, I get sleepy.
Lucia: 我去把这个凳子再给他们搬上去
Lucia: I’ll go take this chair upstairs for them.
Lucia: 要不然上面凳子就不够了
Lucia: Otherwise, there won’t be enough chairs up there.
Lucia: 我又把这凳子给搬上来了
Lucia: I brought the chair up again.
Jake:哎呦好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry about that.
Lucia: 要不然攒一会不够123456
Lucia: Otherwise, we wouldn’t have enough. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Lucia: 要不来俩人坐这上面
Lucia: Maybe two people can sit here instead.
Lucia: 这是谁的
Lucia: Whose is this?
Shure: just do it just you
Shure: Just do it, just you.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh man.
Lucia: 这灯要不就把它放这这样转过来
Lucia: Should we place this light here and turn it around?
Lucia: 因为咱接下来两天还要练舞的话
Lucia: Because we need to practice dancing for the next two days.
Lucia: 那他就可以一直在这打着对吧
Lucia: So it can keep shining here, right?
Lucia: 这个搬一点吃饭用
Lucia: Move this a bit for dining use.
Shure: 要不插到花盆里
Shure: How about sticking it in the flowerpot?
Jake:外观不够高
Jake: The appearance isn't high enough.
Jake:正好有一个什么东西
Jake: There's just something...
Jake:这样的都不行
Jake: This won't work either.
Shure: 哎呦不行
Shure: Oh no, it won't work.
Jake:再多一点或者硬一点的东西
Jake: We need something a bit more or harder.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 把它翻过来然后
Lucia: Turn it over and then...
Lucia: 翻过来扣在这上面
Lucia: Turn it over and put it on top of this.
Jake:翻过来放在下面
Jake: Turn it over and place it underneath.
Lucia: 哦然后在上面再垫个纸
Lucia: Oh, then put a piece of paper on top.
Lucia: 那估计还行
Lucia: That might work.
Lucia: 这里面有没有垃圾
Lucia: Is there any trash in here?
Shure: 红线划过深层
Shure: The red line cut through the deep layer.
Lucia: 哇这个这这个
Lucia: Wow, this... this...
Lucia: 这个空调怎么关啊
Lucia: How do you turn off this air conditioner?
Lucia: 这上面吹的好冷
Lucia: It's blowing so cold from above.
Shure: 喊他关他就关了
Shure: Just tell it to turn off and it will.
Lucia: 真的吗语音控制的
Lucia: Really? Voice-controlled?
Shure: 这不是这是电视遥控器
Shure: No, this is the TV remote.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Shure: 我们一会可能会热
Shure: We might get hot later.
Shure: 所以一会再开对
Shure: So we can turn it on later.
Jake:一会再开吧
Jake: Let's turn it on later.
Lucia: 对一会要上来煮火锅的话再开
Lucia: Yeah, if we're going to have hotpot later, we can turn it on then.
Jake:是吗啊
Jake: Really?
Shure: 竖竖向是吗
Shure: Is it vertical?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 要帮忙吗
Lucia: Need any help?
Shure: 一二哎
Shure: One, two, hey!
Jake:暂暂且不要
Jake: Not for now.
Jake:可能就要了
Jake: Maybe soon though.
Lucia: 感觉你们俩小心
Lucia: Be careful, you two.
Lucia: 哎这我来扶
Lucia: Hey, let me hold this.
Jake:果然还是要帮忙
Jake: Looks like we do need help after all.
Lucia: 碰到这个
Lucia: Hit this part.
Jake:继续吧
Jake: Keep going.
Shure: 你的屁股蹭到了是吗
Shure: Did your butt brush against it?
Jake:这个地方夹到
Jake: It's stuck here.
Shure: 啊我以为是臀部太翘了
Shure: Oh, I thought it was because your butt was too big.
Shure: 好差不多差不多
Shure: Okay, almost done.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 然后煮火锅时候大家把门关好
Shure: When cooking hotpot, make sure to close the door.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Got it.
Shure: 不然话熏的屋里都是那个味
Shure: Otherwise, the whole room will smell like it.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 那个就先暂且这样吧
Lucia: Let's leave it like this for now.
Lucia: 额
Lucia: Uhh.
Jake:来摆桌子
Jake: Let's set the table.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake:正好吧
Jake: Perfect, right?
Lucia: 椅子有6个
Lucia: There are six chairs.
Shure: 啊上午的时候桌子没擦
Shure: Oh, the table wasn't wiped in the morning.
Lucia: 然后再
Lucia: And then...
Shure: 擦一下
Shure: Wipe it.
Lucia: 这个这个腿每次都会掉下来吗
Lucia: Does this leg fall off every time?
Shure: 他是吊脚脚
Shure: It's a hanging leg.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Lucia: 斯 往哪边推比较
Lucia: Pushing it this way is better.
Lucia: 把这俩凳子都放到这边
Lucia: Put these two chairs over here.
Lucia: 然后把那个推到那边
Lucia: Then push that one over there.
Lucia: 能推
Lucia: Can you push it?
Lucia: 能推下
Lucia: Can you push it down?
Jake:可以再来点
Jake: You can add more.
Jake:很有意思
Jake: Interesting.
Jake:很很有意思
Jake: Very interesting.
Lucia: 对楼下还有
Lucia: There's more downstairs.
Jake:到时候再搬上来
Jake: We'll move it up later.
Jake:两个有好处
Jake: Two is good.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Nice.
Shure: 慢得和你走到3的
Shure: Slow like you walking to the third.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Lucia: 现在都上去吗
Lucia: Are we going up now?
Tasha: 毛都说的上去
Tasha: Mao said to go up.
Jake:都来了
Jake: Everyone's here.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:哎呦我的妈呀
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice:吓我一跳
Alice: You scared me.
Alice:怎么还黄
Alice: Why is it still yellow?
Tasha: 嗯没有人
Tasha: Hmm, no one's here.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 来吧我们摆锅摆菜准备开始
Shure: Come on, let's set up the pot and the dishes and get ready.
Lucia: 菜的话
Lucia: About the dishes...
Alice:厕所有人吗
Alice: Is someone in the bathroom?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Shure: 没有吧
Shure: Probably not.
Tasha: 应该没有吧
Tasha: I don't think so.
Shure: 没有咱们都在
Shure: No, we're all here.
Shure: 然后那个那谁还在咖啡厅
Shure: And someone is still in the café.
Shure: 其他都回来了
Shure: The rest are back.
Tasha: 上面怎么这么冷
Tasha: Why is it so cold upstairs?
Lucia: 因为之前空调一直开着
Lucia: Because the air conditioning was on earlier.
Shure: 刚开空调然后现在关了
Shure: It was just turned on and now it's off.
Alice: 这锁好的吗
Alice: Is this lock secure?
Shure: 这锁是坏的
Shure: This lock is broken.
Shure: 但是我们不会进的
Shure: But we won't go in.
Lucia: 那个锁是坏的
Lucia: That lock is broken.
Lucia: 这锁还是好的
Lucia: This lock is still good.
Lucia: 左边这锁好
Lucia: The left lock works.
Alice: 上个左边的
Alice: Use the left one.
Lucia: 所以大家在这里上洗手间的时候
Lucia: So when everyone uses the bathroom here,
Lucia: 要养成先敲门的习惯
Lucia: you should get into the habit of knocking first.
Shure: 真的没人
Shure: There's really no one.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No one.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Shure: 不至于神兼兮兮
Shure: No need to be so paranoid.
Lucia: 哦这有牛奶锅
Lucia: Oh, there's a milk pot here.
Lucia: 这是他这带的
Lucia: Did he bring this?
Lucia: 还是咱们的呀
Lucia: Or is it ours?
Shure: 我的咖啡壶
Shure: It's my coffee pot.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 当我没说哈哈哈sorry
Lucia: Forget I said that, haha, sorry.
Alice: 虽然没坏但是没有纸
Alice: Although it's not broken, there's no paper.
Tasha:哈
Tasha: Ha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia: 啊太饿了
Lucia: Ah, I'm so hungry.
Tasha: 我也好饿呀
Tasha: I'm really hungry too.
Lucia: 让我看看这有什么吃的
Lucia: Let me see what food we have here.
Tasha: 我们把绿豆饼吃了吧
Tasha: Let's eat the mung bean cakes.
Lucia: 我支持我支持
Lucia: I'm all for it, I'm all for it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Lucia: 哈哈那我们下去睡
Lucia: Haha, then let's go to sleep downstairs.
Tasha: 好啊
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 还是在这
Lucia: Or stay here.
Tasha: 要不要拿上来吃
Tasha: Should we bring it upstairs to eat?
Lucia: 拿上来也行
Lucia: Bringing it up works too.
Lucia: 那会就放这个冰箱里行
Lucia: Then we can just put it in the fridge.
Tasha: 行啊哈哈好饿呀
Tasha: Sure, haha, I'm so hungry.
Lucia: 哈哈哈可以可以
Lucia: Hahaha, sounds good, sounds good.
Lucia: 这个都拿上去
Lucia: Bring all of this upstairs.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 这个额
Lucia: This, um...
Lucia: 先这样吧
Lucia: Let's do this first.
Lucia: 然后微微刚才说拿的那个
Lucia: And then, what Tasha mentioned earlier...
Lucia: 哦是这个
Lucia: Oh, it's this one.
Lucia: 呃这是我的
Lucia: Uh, this is mine.
Lucia: 嗯我已经拿出来了
Lucia: Yeah, I've already taken it out.
Tasha: 还有东西要拿吗
Tasha: Is there anything else to take?
Tasha: 我就问肉
Tasha: I'm just asking about the meat.
Lucia: 啊就是火锅用的东西
Lucia: Ah, it's for the hot pot.
Tasha: 对对
Tasha: Right, right.
Lucia: 基本上可以都拿上去
Lucia: We can basically bring it all up.
Lucia: 咕嘟咕嘟嘟嘟嘟
Lucia: Glug glug glug glug
Lucia: 丁
Lucia: Ding
Lucia: 啊要命
Lucia: Ah, it's killing me.
Tasha: 还有蒜蒜
Tasha: There's still garlic.
Lucia: ok
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Tasha: 楼上有一个卡式炉
Tasha: There's a cassette stove upstairs.
Tasha: 再拿一个电磁炉就行
Tasha: Just bring an induction cooker.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 插排拿过来
Shure: Bring the power strip over.
Shure: 插排不够长吧
Shure: The power strip isn't long enough, right?
Shure: 够吗
Shure: Is it enough?
Shure: 插排不够长
Shure: The power strip isn't long enough.
Shure: 再接个插排
Shure: Connect another power strip.
Jake:打牌不够长
Jake: The game isn't long enough.
Jake:再接呗再接一个
Jake: Let's play another round.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 排接排
Shure: Another round.